es gibt gerade ordentlich zoff um
unseren geliebten duden ich sage nur
ländern ja bei berufs- und
funktionsbezeichnung wird die
geschlechts übergreifende bedeutung
getilgt das heißt becker ist man dann im
online duden nur noch als penis inhaber
alle anderen sind bäckerinnen und
darüber regen sich jetzt halt leute auf
meine sicher über neuschöpfung wie
gästen wunder ich mich privat auch aber
unabhängig von dem was im duden steht
darf man ja trotzdem weiter reden wie
man will
ein sehr sehr emotionales thema und
genau das ist eigentlich total gesund
meint jedenfalls till reiners dass wut
workout mit till reiners und wenn ich
sage männer den frauen ausdrücklich mit
gemeint wir können nicht mehr raus
mannes gestrichen was bleibt uns noch
wuchs das kaminfeuer der gefühle stärkt
sein immunsystem 20 minuten aufregend
wie zwei stunden joggen und was macht
nicht wütend genau ländern
leg dich auf der dover duden und wir
nehmen den duden in den schraubstock des
hasses und hassen und hassen
in der neuen online version ist der
mieter jetzt nur noch männlich frauen
sollen plötzlich mieterin heißen wie
würden wir das scheiße hier die besten
gute reaktion auf sendern mit denen du
deine männlichkeit wieder stark macht wo
soll das alles enden die spinnen doch
eben dafür denkt man sich absoluten
quatsch aus und behauptet einfach alle
die gern wollen absurden quatsch man
sollte das doch machen wie zb in
südafrika woher dieses macht die
politikerinnen die bundeskanzlerin
also verrückter geht's schon gar nicht
klar
also man könnte auch einfach so privat
für sich reaktionär bleiben und
mieterinnen weiter mieter nennen also
macht er gar keinen spaß
nächster wut über
probleme erfinden die gar nicht da sind
seit neuesten darf ich laut dem hinweis
nach medikamenten werbung nicht mal mehr
meinen arzt fragen ich darf nur meine
ärzte ärztinnen fragen werden jetzt
ganze berufe weg geändert ja allererste
werden erschossen hat der duden sowohl
machst du nichts außer dem was haben
frauen nicht schon alles von uns
gekriegt die dürfen wählen reduzierter
mehrwertsteuersatz auf tampon sein
letztem jahr ja alle vier wochen
spontaner jubel schreiben dumarey markt
so und jetzt nicht schlapp machen
weiter geht's mit dem power argument die
deutsche sprache wird verhunzt
ja und ich sprachen nämlich extrem
wichtig ich wollte was lesen männer
gerne die bedienungsanleitung vom grill
sterz nur frauen lesen
bedienungsanleitungen wir kippen 5 liter
benzin rüber zünden jahren und werfen 36
rhein-neckar als wenn irgendwer nachdem
nun reden würde
leute die sonst schland grund durch die
straßen torkeln machen meinem sender
nine novell berlin nicht freut weil
sinnloses aufhängen gesundes und nächste
woche reden wir über transsexuelle es
gibt sie wirklich und wie finden wir
diese simple tatsache gibt es schon
wortmeldung mein vater ist jetzt eine
frau also ich bin super bernd schramm
einen duden nach videos jetzt nennen
muss papa papa wo soll das alles enden
aber hauptsache dass wut workout mit
till reiners
hallo leute ich bin der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und 70 -
wollt dann abonniert jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist - der stelle